let's go next to our caller from the
three one nine area code
who's calling today from three one nine
yeah hey David my name is Phil wing and
I'm a student here I want to state
universities and I was also still
organizing on campus for burning and my
question for you is what do you think
about the DNC potentially adding
super-delegates in the first round well
I think we all know exactly why they're
thinking about it right mm-hmm right
yeah
so for people who don't know let me just
explain fooling for a second in 2016
there were these things called
super-delegates and so you know Bernie
and Hillary would have a primary and
then they'd like split the pledged
delegates but then you would be shown on
corporate media a running total and it
would add pledged delegates to
super-delegates and it was like Hillary
had already sealed the thing and these
are party officials and others who in
2016 got to vote along with the pledged
delegates at the Democratic National
Convention to select the nominee it's
completely anti-democratic so the DNC
under pressure since 2016 said okay
we're going to give just the pledged
delegates who are earned by winning
primaries the first round of voting
without super-delegates
however if the pledged delegates don't
determine a winner then in the second
round of voting super-delegates come in
this was considered more democratic and
probably good for an outsider candidate
like Bernie Sanders now that Bernie has
been surging there are numerous reports
including in Politico that the DNC is
again thinking of could we put
super-delegates back in that first round
of voting and it's very transparent that
the goal would be to deny Bernie the
nomination now the one thing that that I
did read is that even though it's a
discussion it seems that the DNC knows
that would it would be extremely
problematic to do it and there would be
massive blowback so I've read they're
talking about it but not that they're
determined to do it okay yeah because I
was just I was just pretty curious about
that just because like clapping and 16
and stuff like that and right now since
I'm an Iowa it's like you know there's
and like it's been pretty sketchy around
here you know like hopes are running
high and everything like that
like most of the delegates like we like
the major hubs were Bernie won they
still not counted yet so it's just
like.how and it's like hockey was taken
in the lead like he came the early
victory in the media kind of went with
that so it's just like it's like I feel
like a relief VP of 16 again with these
keys putting their hands we should it be
yeah well you know as people will be
able to tell us as of this recording we
we don't have yet but the we don't have
100% counted yet but then I don't I'm
not completely sure that once we get to
a hundred percent things are going to
drastically reverse from where they are
now I think we just have to wait and see
yeah sounds good
all right full win great to hear from
you appreciate the phone call very very
much